[Applause]
i have some questions for you
sure we're going to put you on the hot
seat very good
are you ready chris i live in the hot
seat okay
so you say i'm nervous
okay here we go
the speed limit is reduced in school
zones
should pedophiles be forced to drive
faster
no they should just be stopped on site
and arrested immediately
yeah that's a great answer that's a good
answer he got you that's one point chris
[ __ ] zero andrew son of a [ __ ] okay i
have a feeling it's not over yet though
you have eight emmys ten actually oh god
damn
point two three zero i was saving that i
didn't want to interrupt you
you have ten emmys okay um but emmy
is a young girl's name do you feel
conflicted that you have that
no i feel like you need eight more oh
i think we might get a couple more with
these discovery players yeah
here we go okay okay um did you ever
think about doing an episode
in a church in boston come on
you know i was wondering how you're
welcome in the catholic church
i mean just walk in who wants it
right that's the easiest episode in the
world well you know
you watch spotlight you know the movie
and you see what these guys went through
to report that story and it's really
it's really a compelling narrative yeah
and they went through hell to report it
yeah and that shows the power and the
economic power of the catholic church no
but like if they see you
do you think they're trying to like
poison the wafer they give you did they
start sweating
oh i you know i've spoken to the the
conference of uh
bishops and and um
you know i i don't there's no real
relationship with the catholic church
but
you know i've i've i think i'm on their
radar not for bad reasons but
you know just for okay you're not out
yet
what is the biggest giveaway that
someone's a pedophile and why is it
wearing crocs
because they're easy to get in and out
of oh
that's point four he's heating up and
they're quiet when you come creepy
oh yo that's a good point and they got
the back strap you know so you can run
if you need to you lock in and go for it
yeah okay fine final question
are you ready ready when are you going
to investigate the judges
on toddlers and trs bombshell
it's a great glass that's a hard one
probably take a look
yeah you should okay they're judging the
hotness of little kids so no
that makes me so so horrible and i don't
know anything about the show so i
shouldn't say
you don't need it off my mouth it's just
the whole notion of it and it brings me
back to you know covering the jean
beneath yeah so many years ago and just
is that necessary it's not not at all
super weird
not at all yeah i think we should get
rid of it yeah
i might know the man to do it i'll
report back boom that's five for five
you